[Musique]
seules les touches vous êtes chaud
aujourd'hui je vous apprendre à danser
la de leurs modèles on accueille les
danseurs série les boys vous êtes prêts
on dément retourner c'est le retour ne
agacé 3,4 y est c'est parti lâchée sexy
les épaules en arrière on avance un peu
on est sexy ouais je suis beau 360 et je
piétine en gardant bien l'ange dans la
bien en voilà
aboyer ça c'est mes boys de leurs
modèles alors on y va
je sens que j'ai vous aussi vous êtes
chose vous n'êtes tout compris à la
musique c'est parti
[Musique]
il est rare
en mode m alors on va compliquer un
petit peu parce que je suis sûr vous
avez le niveau
alors quand vous êtes ici on complique
un peu avec les bras à chaque fois oui
ça c'est bien ça c'est bien et le final
attention le pas je m'offre de leurs
modèles vous avez tout compris vous êtes
chaud alors je vois toute la prudence et
c'est là de leurs modèles
[Musique]
bravo c'est vous et on se retrouve très
vite pour une nouvelle de leurs modèles
[Applaudissements]
modeste
las de leur hôtel
tél
le
google
[Musique]
ok